alfredo mete 3800 en una cuenta de
ahorros el banco le proporcionarán el
1.8 de interés en el dinero de la cuenta
cada año el 1.8 por ciento de interés u
otra forma de decir lo mismo sería que
el dinero en la cuenta de ahorros
crecerá en un 1.8 por ciento por año
escribe una expresión que describan
cuánto dinero abre la cuenta en 15 años
vamos a pensar un poco en esto vamos a
poner por aquí el monto inicial déjame
ponerlo en el inicio déjame ponerlo así
en el inicio que bueno es lo mismo que
el año cero
alfredo a meter tres mil ochocientos
pesos es justo lo que me están diciendo
aquí entonces alfredo me meten tres mil
ochocientos pesos a este banco ahora
vamos a pensar qué es lo que pasa en el
primer año déjame ponerlo con este color
si pensamos un poco en lo que está
pasando en él
año 1 después de que transcurrió un año
bueno lo que va a pasar es lo siguiente
es el freedom va a tener 3 mil 800 pesos
que es justo lo que metió al banco pero
esto le vamos a aumentar el 1.8 por
ciento de interés eso lo podemos
escribir como el 1.8 por ciento ok de 3
mil 800 es decir por 3 mil 800 y bueno
si esto lo escribimos en su forma
decimal esto es exactamente lo mismo que
bueno 3 mil 800 3 mil 800 más y el 1.8
por ciento de interés es lo mismo que el
0 puntos 0 18 escrito en forma decimal
entonces si pongo el primero el 3 mil
803 mil 800 que multiplica a 0.0 18 que
es lo mismo que 1.8 por ciento es decir
18 sobre 1000 y ahora de aquí podemos
hacer una
aplicación matemática que nos va a ser
bastante útil ya que podemos factorizar
de aquí y de aquí un 3800 porque si en
este caso factor y sobre este 3800 por
qué no hacerlo entonces que me quedaría
bueno esto sería exactamente lo mismo
que 3800 que va a multiplicar y bueno
primero multiplicar a 11 por 3.800 es
3800 más y después multiplicando a
observar a 0.0 18 estás de acuerdo y
ahora esto lo puedo escribir de una
manera más sencilla como 3.800 que
multiplica a 1.0 18 si sumo estos dos de
lujo así que éste me parece un momento
interesante para pausar el vídeo todavía
no tenemos la respuesta completa es
decir lo que vamos a obtener en 15 años
pero tenemos una expresión interesante
para cuánto vamos a obtener después
el primer año noten que es el dinero
está creciendo en un 1.8 por ciento por
año esto es lo mismo que multiplicar por
0 puntos 0 18 esto es equivalente a
multiplicar el monto con el que
empezamos por uno más el monto por el
cual está creciendo o por 1.0 18 una vez
más porque esto tiene un sentido
intuitivo bueno es que al final del año
1 vamos a tener el monto original que
tuvimos y es justo lo que representa
este 1 ya esto le vamos a sumar el
montón por el que está creciendo
entonces lo multiplican por éste
0.0 18 y cuando nos tomamos la suma de
estos dos al final nos quedan el monto
original esto fue lo que metió alfredo y
a eso lo vamos a multiplicar por 1.0 18
y eso nos va a dar lo que tenemos al
final del primer año así que pausa el
vídeo y ve si puedes encontrar lo que va
a suceder en el año 2 y
e intentar encontrar lo que sucederá en
15 años bueno y qué hay del año 2
entonces en el año 2 con cuánto vamos a
empezar déjenme escribirlo en el año dos
buenos ya sabemos con lo que vamos a
empezar vamos a empezar con lo que
terminamos en el año 1 que es justo esto
que tengo aquí así que déjame escribirlo
vamos a empezar con 3.800 que
multiplican a 1.0 18 ahora bien a esta
cantidad de aquí vamos a hacer que
crezcan en un 1.8 por ciento que es el
interés que le toca ese año o dicho de
otra manera va a crecer en 10.0 18 y ya
dijimos que si vamos a crecer ese monto
es equivalente a multiplicar por 1.0 18
así que vamos a hacerlo a esta cantidad
de aquí la voy a multiplicar por
1.0 18 de lujo y si te das cuenta esto
se puede simplificar esto es exactamente
lo mismo que 3800 que multiplican a 1.0
18 esto elevado al cuadrado y estoy
seguro que ya ves hacia dónde va esto si
cada año crecemos en un 1.8 de interés
entonces por cada año que pasa vamos a
multiplicar por un nuevo 1.0 18 y si
estamos pensando en 15 años en el futuro
vamos a hacer esto 15 veces así que
observa en nuestro primer año nuestro
exponente era uno de lujo en nuestro
segundo año nuestro exponente es 2 es
este que tenemos aquí entonces si
pensamos en el año 15 que es lo que va a
pasar en el año
15 lo que vamos a tener es si vamos al
grano vamos a tener el monto inicial que
eran tres mil ochocientos y esto lo
vamos a multiplicar por 1.0 18
esta vez elevado a la potencia 15 es
decir lo que vamos a obtener al final
del año 15 es 3 mil 800 que multiplican
a 1.0 18 15 veces y de hecho a esto se
le conoce como crecimiento compuesto
donde cada año van a crecer el máximo
del monto que tenían antes y una de las
cosas divertidas es que si metes esto es
la calculadora que incluso un 1.8 por
ciento por año no parece la gran cosa
pero durante 15 años al meter esto en la
calculadora obtienes un monto razonable
pero bueno esta es la expresión nos
están pidiendo una expresión que
describa cuánto dinero habrá en la
cuenta en 15 años y por lo tanto no nos
están pidiendo meter esto a la
calculadora